[TITLE MUSIC PLAYING]
MAYANK BANSAL: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I am Mayank Bansal, and I'm a
research scientist at Waymo.
Today, I'm going to be
talking about teaching a car
to drive itself.
We are going to walk through the
design of ChauffeurNet, which
is a deep-learned
driving network.
But before we do, let's
look at some examples
of this network driving a
real car at our test facility.
Here is an example
demonstrating lane
following down a curved road.
You can look at both the
overhead view as well as
the camera view to witness
the smoothness of the drive.
The second example demonstrates
stopping for a stop sign.
The car detects the
stop sign, slows down,
comes to a full stop,
and then continues
with a right turn, all of it
being executed by ChauffeurNet.
The change in the
color of the car
indicates braking
issued by the net.
Now let's jump right into
designing this network.
And, in order to
do that, we first
need to define the scope of
what this network will do.
So here is a quick
overview of what
a typical self-driving
software stack looks like.
So you start from
sensor data, which
could come from a
multitude of sensors,
like cameras,
radars, and lasers.
And then a perception module
takes all that sensor data
and converts it into a
higher-level representation,
for example, where all the
objects are, how they're
moving, their speeds,
accelerations,
what is the state of
traffic lights, and so on.
All of this information is then
fed to a behavior prediction
module.
This module is responsible for
predicting possible futures
for objects.
For example, there's
a car in front--
is it going to turn left,
turn right, or stay stopped,
things like that.
Then, all of this
information goes further
into a planning module.
This module then absorbs
all this information
and converts it into a
higher-level trajectory
representation.
This representation might be in
the form of a sequence of poses
or in some other representation.
But essentially, you
take this and feed it
to a controls optimizer.
The controls
optimizer is the one
which is optimizing,
through this trajectory,
to convert it to throttle
and steering commands, which
ultimately the controller
onboard the car will
use to drive the car forward.
Now when it comes
to actually thinking
about machine learning
for the driving task,
we have a number of options.
We can either replace each
of the independent modules
with ML, or replace
multiple of them together.
One of the approaches which
sits at one end of the spectrum
is called end-to-end driving.
In this case, you
replace the entire stack
with a single
machine-learned model
which starts directly
from sensor data
and directly produces throttle
and steering commands.
You can also do
mid-to-mid driving.
In this case, you produce
a high-level trajectory
instead of directly outputting
throttle and steering commands.
And instead of starting
from sensor data,
you start from a
higher-level representation
that was generated by
the perception module.
This is precisely
the representation
we'll use for ChauffeurNet.
To go into more detail, here
is a view of what exactly
the input looks like.
So the input is like
a top-down view,
with the rendering of the
perception output in the form
of these white boxes.
And the output will be
the sequence of poses
which is our trajectory
representation here.
Now, there are a
number of advantages
to this particular
representation.
First, since we are
using perception output,
it allows us to
decouple the complexity
of learning a perception system
from the complexity of learning
a driver.
Then, we can also use any
other perception algorithm,
independent of how
we train the model.
And finally, if we want to train
and evaluate in simulation,
we can do it without having
to bother about how would we
actually generate sensor data in
simulation, because perception
can actually be generated
much easily in simulation.
Now that we have defined
this scope for this network,
let's think about how the
inputs and outputs will be more
precisely defined.
So we start with our
top-down or bird's eye view,
like I showed in
the previous slide.
In this case, we fixed 80
meters by 80 meters world
representation.
And our agent, or
the self-driving car,
would be placed at a specific
location within this view.
This is shown by the
white box in this figure.
Then we'll represent
all the context
around the SDC or the agent
in the same coordinate system.
So the first image
shows a road map,
which represents all the known
a priori features of the map.
For instance, you
see the lane markers,
the center line shown as
yellow, the crosswalks in blue.
And we can add a lot of
features, like stop signs,
the presence of traffic lights,
and so on, in the same map.
Now, when it comes
to traffic lights,
we need to convey
to the net what
is the state of traffic lights.
This is, again, being generated
by the perception system.
In this picture, we show
how we represent that.
These are all center lanes of
the lanes in this same grid
as the map, and the
intensities encode
the traffic light states.
So in this particular
example, the brighter shades
would reflect a red light,
and the other shades
would reflect green light.
This is the speed limit channel,
again encoding different speeds
with different
intensity profiles.
Now, the perception objects
which we talked about before--
in this case, it's a
sequence of images--
we want the net to know
exactly how they were moving
over the past time frame.
So we have a sequence of images
going from the past one or two
seconds.
And for each of
those timestamps,
we'll have a single slice
of the sequence, which
shows all the objects in this
scene as these bounding boxes,
which are colored white here.
In a similar
representation, we also
want to show how exactly
our agent was placed
and its heading, which is
shown by the white box here.
Now, to convey how
the agent actually
was moving in the past,
we also have a channel
which shows a sequence of dots.
Each of these pixels
is the location
of the agent over the past--
some timestamp in the past.
And finally, we want
to convey to the net
exactly what we want
the agent to do.
So this is the planned route
channel which conveys that.
So if we look at
it closely, this
is essentially a
Google-Maps-style
representation
which shows that we
want the agent to actually turn
right in the next few seconds.
Now, given all this
information, we
want the net to
output a trajectory.
As I said before,
this trajectory
is in the form of
these waypoints which
are shown by this animated
set of green dots.
Now we have defined
this scope as well as
the inputs and outputs.
The next point here
is to actually pick up
a model architecture.
For our first model, we'll use
a convolutional recurrent neural
network.
So this is a
high-level schematic
of what this network
will look like.
So, if you follow the picture
with me from top to bottom,
you start with the
rendered inputs,
you pass them through a set
of convolutional layers, which
is shown as a feature net here.
That produces an embedding
of all the inputs
the net has seen.
And that gets passed
on to Agent RNN.
This Agent RNN is
actually directed
in part of the net which is
responsible for producing
a sequence of waypoints which,
together, from the trajectory.
Now, for each of
those waypoints,
you want some metadata,
which is shown
by these different
arrows, with heading speed
as well as what the
box looks like at each
of those waypoints.
And as we can see in the
bottom part of the picture,
all of these
predictions are guided
by the ground route
known from the log data,
and are driven by usual losses.
Now, to look at it in a
little bit more detail,
this is a blow-up of some
parts of the network.
If you focus on the output of
Agent RNN, on the top right,
you can see a
predicted location PK.
Now, this predicted location
PK is one particular output.
You actually produce
that, and then update
a memory, M. This memory gets
fed back into the Agent RNN,
and the Agent RNN
then can then use this
to produce the next waypoint.
On the bottom
right, we show what
it does for the agent boxes.
It has a similar
reference to produce
a sequence of box locations.
So in a sense, the Agent RNN is
taking in all the input data,
and conditioned on whatever
it has predicted till now,
it's actually predicting
the very next waypoint.
And in this way, it can
predict the entire trajectory.
Now, once we have this model,
we generated training data
by sampling 26 million examples
from lots of our driving logs,
and then we trained the model.
Now comes the interesting part.
Now that we have
a model trained,
the question is, how
exactly do we evaluate it?
Unlike traditional ML
models, in this case,
we want this model to be
able to drive the car.
So it's important
to pay attention
to exactly how we evaluate it.
As I'll discuss next, there
are two approaches in which
we can evaluate this model--
open loop and
closed loop control.
So this is the traditional
way in which you typically
evaluate models.
In the diagram here, you take
the locked poses as well as
all your input data for
a given test example.
You feed it through the net, and
then you predict the waypoints
and compare them
to the ground route
to actually get an idea of how
well the network is performing.
But if you really want the net
to be able to drive the car,
you need to think about it in
a slightly different manner.
That brings us to
closed loop control.
So in this case, once you
have the predicted waypoints,
you actually feed them
to a vehicle simulator.
Think of it as a simulation
of the vehicle dynamics.
In practice, in reality, this
will be the actual vehicle
taking in those waypoints.
Now, for evaluating
in simulation,
we'll use the vehicle
simulator, which
will use these waypoints
to drive the car forward.
Because of that, the car
might actually drive forward
and generate new poses.
Now, an interesting
aspect of this
is that those poses might
be very different from what
the net was trained at.
Now, given that, it would
be really hard for the net
to generalize if it has
never seen this data
or it actually lands
outside its distribution.
So it's important to
evaluate the network,
both in open loop as well
as closed loop settings.
So let's look at
what our network does
in our very first test.
So the very first test is the
simple task of lane following.
We find that it's able to
follow lanes seamlessly
in the open loop, but in
closed loop, it goes off road.
Now, let's look at why that is.
So here is a single
test example.
The blue dots are the
past, and red dots
are the future locations
predicted by the net.
You can see that these locations
are well-aligned with the lane
boundaries, which shows that
the agent did a good job using
this net as a driver.
Now consider these
other two examples.
These were generated in a
closed-loop setting, where
the lane lines had a
slight offset in the angle
relative to the image
coordinate system.
As you can see, the
red dots are no longer
aligned with the lanes.
In fact, they're taking
the car off road.
Closer attention in
these green boxes
shows that the red
dots are more or less
aligned with the image axis.
So what's happening
here is that the net
has learned a bias from
the top-down orientation
of the input data.
All of our input
data was rendered
with a specific
orientation, and the net
has learned that
that orientation is
much more important than
the lane orientation.
So we really want the
net to be able to learn
what it is like to
drive along the lanes,
and not along the image axis.
So what we do here
to resolve that
is to actually render
the training data
with a whole bunch of
randomized heading offsets.
So here are three
examples of different ways
in which we have
oriented the input.
So when it goes through
the training pipeline,
the net can actually focus
on the lane orientations.
So this is one
example of the kind
of domain-specific perturbations
we might need to actually make
the ML system work.
Now, the next task that
we evaluated the net at
was related to stop signs.
So once again we
find, in open loop,
the agent stops for a stop
sign, but in closed loop,
it actually never stops, and
continues driving past them.
Now, this one is a little
bit more interesting.
So if you consider
what's happening
in most of our
training data, we find
that most of our
training data has
past motion profile,
which is already
braking for the stop sign.
So the agent is already
braking for these top lanes
when it comes into
its field of view.
Now, because of that,
the net doesn't actually
learn that it has to slow
down for the stop sign.
It rather learns that
if for just purely
extrapolates from that
data, it can come to a stop.
Now if you apply
the same analogy
to the closed-loop
setting, we find
that, in most
closed-loop examples,
an agent is actually
approaching the stop
sign at a constant speed.
Now, because of
that, the net again
extrapolates, continues
driving at constant speeds,
and just runs off the stop sign.
So once again, the
important point
is the net has learned a bias,
this time, not from the way
the data was generated, but just
from the characteristic of what
it has been fed.
So the bias in this case
is from the past motion,
and we really want
to remove that to be
able to avoid this bias.
But the issue is it's
important for the net
to know what speed and
acceleration the car
was driving with so it can
actually predict the future.
So we can't really
remove that past motion.
Instead, what we do
here is we propose
adding dropout on these poses.
What that means in practice is
that for a subset of examples,
we actually remove
the past motion,
but we do keep it for
the rest of the examples.
And that lets the net
actually learn that,
to explain the stop sign,
it has to really look
not on the past poses, but
on the real things which
are rendered into the input.
Now we found the agent followed
lane lines, it came to a stop.
But now an interesting
problem came up--
it never moved after that.
It really got stuck.
Again, this difference
was pretty evident
between open and
closed-loop evaluation.
And unlike the other
two cases, this really
has to do with the way we
have modeled the problem.
So we are using a
recurrent neural network
to actually predict the
successive waypoints.
But if you consider
the problem of what
happens when you
want to really move
the agent from a
standstill, you really
need to focus on the
first few waypoints
adding an incremental
amount of motion.
Now, the RNN, in our
case, doesn't know
which waypoint it's predicting.
So the very first
waypoint it predicts
has a small motion,
which might be subpixel,
and it doesn't move the
agent forward at all.
Next time through, it again sees
that the agent is where it was,
and it again issues
a small motion.
Compounding that together,
the agent never moves.
So, in a sense, the
RNN keeps predicting
less than one pixel
motion, and that's not
enough to move
the agent forward.
So a solution to
that, in this case,
was actually modification
of the network itself.
We focus on the teal
box that we have added.
It tells the network
what waypoint
it's actually predicting.
So for the first waypoint,
it knows it's the first one.
And by, let's say,
the fifth waypoint,
since it knows it's the fifth
waypoint, it can issue a bigger
motion, irrespective of how
much it has moved along.
And that gets it unstuck.
Till now we have looked
at a number of issues
we saw in the model.
And, for each of those, we saw a
number of ways to resolve them.
For orientation bias, we
looked at data augmentation.
For motion bias related
to the past motion,
we looked at the input dropout.
And then, for an issue with
the model architecture itself,
we had to improve
with the model itself.
Now that we have
this model, we'll
call this as an imitation model.
And that's because we have
used purely supervised data
to train this network.
Now let's look at what
happens when we actually
evaluate this model in a
closed-loop setting in a more
complex scenario.
In this video, pay
attention to the gray box,
which is the agent being
driven by the imitation model.
As it continues driving, we
find that it drifts and lands
on top of the yellow line.
So the agent is not able
to maintain its trajectory,
and over time it slowly drifts.
But because there is
no way for the net
to actually know how to
correct these mistakes,
it is not able to recover.
So in this case, we again
need some sort of mechanism
to teach the net this recovery.
But it cannot be done simply by
augmenting the data the way we
did before.
So consider this
training example.
Here, the red dot is the
current location of the agent.
White dots are the past
poses, and green dots
are the future that we
want the net to predict.
Now, we take this example,
we shift the position
of the agent, which is the
red dot, randomly along one
direction, and we fit
another trajectory
through the red dot and
the first and last points
to generate a smooth profile.
If you look at this
animation here,
you can see that the profile
of the perturbed image
is actually a feasible
driving profile.
And it's really telling
the net that, if you ever
land up in this
situation, how do
you actually bring the agent
back to the center of the lane.
So we can do this with
random amount of shifts
for all our training and data.
And given both our original
as well as perturbed examples,
we can train the net
to basically learn
from both the original data
as well as the perturbations.
Here is a test example of
a perturbed example set.
The second image
shows what happens
with our original model,
which did not know how
to recover from perturbation.
So in this case, you see
that the agent goes off road
because clearly it has no
idea how to bring it back.
Now, this is the result
of the model which
was trained with perturbations.
So as you can see,
it's not completely
reflective of the
ground routes, but it
achieves its goal of actually
bringing the agent back
to the lane center.
So now we'll revisit the example
we had before of the agent
going around the turn
and where it landed
on top of the yellow marker.
So, as we saw here,
the agent no longer
lands on top of
the yellow marker.
It's able to issue small
correction commands to actually
keep it well-aligned in
the center of the lane.
Now we have an imitation
model, and it's
able to perform lane following,
even over longer scenarios.
But are we done yet?
Sort of.
So we find that it's able to
avoid collisions in most cases,
but it doesn't have
the generalization
ability to actually avoid
collisions in new situations.
So here is an example of an
agent approaching a parking
area where you'll see a car
pulling out of its spot.
And as you saw here,
briefly, the agent
passed right through
the unparking car.
So the agent has
learned to avoid
collisions, but clearly
not general enough
to face these situations.
And this situation is rare
enough to not be present a lot,
or even at all, in
our training data.
So how do we fix this?
So going back to the
architecture diagram
of our net, we really want to
teach the net explicitly what
it is like to avoid collisions.
So we do this by adding
a loss that explicitly
measures overlap
of each prediction
with the rest of the scene.
So if you focus
on the inset here,
the yellow box is
the agent which
is predicted at a
particular time,
and the blue boxes
are the bounding boxes
of all the other agents in the
scene know from ground route.
Now, if you overlay
these boxes together,
you can get a fair idea as
to whether the agent has
any overlap with
the other objects.
And if there is an overlap, that
should drive a loss function
to actually update
the model rates to not
perform the action that
generated this overlap.
We can do a similar
thing to avoid collision
with road agents like curves
and so on by painting the road
edge in a view, and then
overlapping it with the agent
to test this loss.
Now, this is good in theory,
but, in practice, this does not
actually solve anything.
The reason being that our
training data has no collision
examples.
Our training data came
from expert driving,
so there were no collisions.
And hence, if you look at these
losses, they'll always be zero,
and would not
update any gradient.
So, for us, the
only reason it works
is because of our
perturbed examples.
So if we look at any of our
synthesized perturbations,
we have made no attempt to
actually resolve collisions.
So lots of those
perturbations will actually
have synthetic collisions,
either with the road
or with other objects.
And all of those
synthetic collisions
will actually have a
non-zero value for this loss.
So using those
synthesized perturbations,
we can actually make
the net use these losses
through our training.
So let's look at that example
again, of an unparking car,
but this time after
having trained it
with the collision loss.
Once again, the
car is approaching
that unparking zone, and
it sort of drifts over,
and nudges around, and avoids
collision with that car.
OK, so far, we have the net
which can avoid collisions,
drive smoothly through the
lane boundaries, and so on.
But we want to do even better.
Typically, in machine
learning, a way
to improve generalization
of any models
is to co-train with other
objectives which might
be relevant to the main task.
For the task of
driving, one such task
is to predict the
future of other agents.
As we saw in the
architecture diagram
for our self-driving
software stack,
behavior prediction is
an important module.
What if we could predict
the future of other objects
together with predicting
our own trajectory?
This is precisely what
we do with the addition
of another network here
that's shown as Perception
RNN in this image.
This is, again, a
recurring neural network.
But instead of predicting
our own future,
it predicts the future of all
the other objects in the scene.
If you pay closer
attention, you can
see that this particular
output is also
driven by the same
set target boxes which
we use for measuring collision.
So in this sense
using the same labels
we can drive this
co-trained output as well.
And because this
particular RNN is
branched from the same feature
net that we use for Agent RNN,
it can actually
improve the feature net
and lead to better performance
for the main task as well.
So these are two examples
of what the predictions
from Perception RNN look like.
So the red and yellow
boxes are the past boxes--
or the past perception
object, and the green trails
are the predictions
from this net.
So it's pretty good in
terms of predicting u-turns,
as well as figuring out the
intent of other object--
when, for example, they're
in a right-turn lane,
whether they're actually
going to make a right
turn or continue straight.
Now, we can also
do the same thing
for the road mask,
which is essentially
a bitmap of drivable
and non-drivable areas.
This is not RNN, because
we just want to know,
in the current map, which area
is drivable and which is not.
And this is another
co-trained output
which we use to actually
drive better features
and then better
performance from agent RNN.
The final piece of the puzzle
that I'm going to talk about
is called imitation dropout.
If you focus on the
losses that we added,
which are in the
green box here, these
are all meant to imitate
what exactly the agent did
in the log data.
In essence, these are
all imitation losses.
All the other losses
that you see here
are meant to just test or
infer how exactly the agent is
coordinating with the
rest of the environment.
Now, in order to make the
net generalize better,
we want to give it some
freedom to explore, even
when it doesn't want
to imitate whatever
it was given in the log.
So to do that, we add
an imitation dropout.
What that means is that for a
random subset of our training
examples, we actually remove
these imitation losses,
and the gradients
are driven entirely
by the rest of the losses.
So for those
examples, the net is
free to explore
whatever alternate
trajectories it wants to.
And then the only basis
for them to be correct
is that they should
interact correctly
with the rest of the
environment, which
is driven by the collision
loss, road mask loss, and so on.
And just empirically, we found
that this particular strategy
works much better than simply
leaving between the losses.
Till now, we have looked
at how the model behaves
and we have shown some example
videos of how we can debug it.
But for a complex
model like this,
we would typically
want a better strategy,
and ablation experiments
is one such strategy
to confirm what the model
has actually learned.
So here is a scenario
where we have drawn a stop
sign with a red block.
We have taken this
same scenario,
and we have removed the stop
sign during the rendering stage
to generate the
scenario on the right.
Now we'll take both
scenarios and run our net
on both of them.
And if it's actually learned
the meaning of a stop sign,
it should behave
differently between the two.
So we can see, in the
video on the left,
the agent comes to a full
stop behind the stop sign,
and then continues
after a short wait.
If you look at the
video on the right,
you can see that, in the
absence of the stop sign,
it merely slows down in
anticipation of the turn
and then continues.
We can perform the
same experiment
with vehicles in the scene.
On the left is this scenario
with all the original vehicles,
which are shown by
these yellow boxes.
On the right, we have
removed these yellow boxes
to simulate the
absence of any traffic.
Once again, if we focus on these
videos one by one, on the left,
the car sees these stopped
cars, it waits behind,
and it does a
stop-and-go, as expected.
On the right, in the
absence of any traffic,
it behaves in a completely
different manner
because there's no reason for
it to stop for anything, which
shows that the agent
has really learned what
we intended for it to learn.
Now, we can perform the
same test at the model net
to really figure out
what is the difference
between the different
models that we have built.
So here's a scenario
we created where
we put a parked car in
the middle of the road
and have our agent approach it.
We find that our
car starts off well.
But as soon as it
sees this parked car,
it slows down, and comes to
a full stop, and gets stuck.
So this is the result
from our imitation model
which doesn't have the
other techniques built in.
Now, if we repeat the same
test for the full model,
we find that the agent is again
able to nicely nudge around
the parked car, and
continues to make progress.
The second scenario
illustrates, again,
recovery from
trajectory perturbation.
So we put our agent at
a slight heading offset,
approaching a tight curve.
And we find that, on the
left, the imitation model
once again gets stuck, not
knowing how to recover,
while the full-weight
model is able to recover
nicely and continue along
the path of the entire turn.
The final scenario is that
of a slow-moving vehicle.
So we put our agent at the
speed limit of the road,
approaching a car moving
at a much slower speed,
and we want to see
how it generalizes.
The imitation model slows
down for the slow-moving car,
but ultimately it keeps slowing
down until it gets stuck.
The full model,
on the other hand,
is able to adjust
its speed, and then
continues making progress in a
typical cruise control fashion.
Those were examples of
some of the log data.
Let's look at some more of
these locked driving examples.
So this is an example of
approaching traffic lights.
Once again, if you recall,
the lane center lines
encode the state
of traffic lights.
In this case, the traffic
lights turn from orange to red,
and the cars in front escape
the light, as expected.
By our agent, instead of
just following behind them,
it comes to a stop
for the red light,
and then continues
as it turns green.
This next example shows stop
sign handling, which all of you
are familiar with by now.
But the interesting
part is the car
is coming out of
a cul-de-sac, it
sees a number of
parked vehicles,
it's able to nudge around,
make way for itself,
and then continues, and
stops for the stop sign.
So the key point
here is these are
all scenarios with different
levels of complexities,
and we can't expect all
of them to be present
in our training data.
So we really need
to teach the net
to generalize to be
able to handle these.
This final example shows
a stop-and-go situation
at a traffic light.
The agent comes behind
a stopped car, stops,
and as the light turns green,
instead of again stopping just
like the other car, it
continues very naturally.
Before we wrap up,
I'd like to showcase
some of the current
issues with the net.
The very first issue
that we see has
to do with the way we have
represented the input.
So the input is a fixed, 80
by 80 meter representation,
and that basically removes a
lot of possibilities in terms
of what the agent can see.
So in the first
video I'll show here,
the agent is approaching a
turn on a fast-moving road.
But because it can't see
the turn soon enough,
it's not able to
execute that turn.
So I believe this is
45-miles-per-hour road.
The yellow box shows what the
car actually did in the log.
But our agent, being too fast
for the turn, simply gets hit.
The second example is one
representative example
of a rare event, for
example, u-turns,
which are not present frequently
enough in our training data.
And so we can't expect
the net to actually
be able to generalize well
to new situations like that.
So in this case, the agent,
which is the green box,
will again try to execute the
route, but will fail to do so.
The yellow box was the box
in the log which correctly
did this maneuver as expected.
And finally, lots of highly
interactive situations which
we encounter every day
during driving, for example,
during lane changes
and merges, those all
involve a lot of
social interaction
for which the net really needs
newer features, for example,
to be able to use
reinforcement learning,
or a real simulator
where you can
simulate these interactions.
In conclusion, what we talked
about today is essentially
that, in order to
solve the driving task,
it's not enough to have
tons of logged driving data,
and that we really need lots
of task-specific techniques
to really simplify the problem
and to help the net everywhere
possible so that it
can generalize across,
away from what it
has seen in the data.
For more details
about this work,
please see our paper as well
as the associated website.
Thanks for all your interest.
Thank you.
[TITLE MUSIC PLAYING]